good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3288
object class
ketter
formerly euclid
special containment procedures
an
scp-3288 population no less than 20 nor
greater than 30 individuals is to be
maintained at humanoid containment site
282. each
scp-3288 must be contained within
individual containment units behavioral
studies that require scp-3288 to
scp-3288 contact are to be conducted
with the utmost caution
scp-3288 are to be terminated where
encountered and disposed of per
hazardous waste protocols
it is imperative that
scp-3288 infestations undergo thorough
destruction or containment as a single
uncontained instance of scp-3288
has the potential to trigger an sk class
dominance shift scenario within the next
century if not sooner
description
scp-3288 designates a highly predatory
species or subspecies of the genus homo
homo anthropophagus
scp-3288 display a number of abnormal
characteristics and behaviors that
distinguish them from the baseline
species the most common deviations
include
acute hyperdontia hyperdontia is the
condition of having supernumerary teeth
or teeth that appear in addition to the
regular number of teeth and macrodontia
macrodontia is the condition of having
abnormally large teeth an instance of
scp-3288 has teeth approximately six
times the size of normal adult teeth
with more than 60 teeth unevenly
distributed over six distinct rows
requiring jaws much larger than that of
baseline humans
gross mandibular prognathism mandibular
prognathism is a potentially disfiguring
genetic disorder where the lower jaw
outgrows the upper resulting in an
extended chin and a crossbite
fluctuating facial asymmetry dolocostano
emilia costanomelia is a condition in
which the limbs are unusually long of
the arms an instance of
scp-3288 commonly has arms more than
twice the length of a baseline human of
similar height
arachnodactyly arachnodactyly is a
condition in which the fingers and toes
are abnormally long and slender in
comparison to the palm of the hand and
arch of the foot and polydactyly
polydactyly is a congenital physical
anomaly in which there are supernumerary
fingers or toes
kyphosis kyphosis is an abnormally
excessive convex caphodic curvature of
the spine as it occurs in the cervical
thoracic and sacral regions it is more
commonly known as hunchback
abnormal muscle strength despite having
the appearance of severe emaciation
albinism
superior low light vision
scp-32881's eyes contain tabitum lucidum
a layer of tissue immediately behind the
retina that reflects visible light back
through the retina increasing the light
available to the photoreceptors and
heterochromia iridium specifically
complete heterochromia complete
heterochromia is when one iris is a
different color from the other the eyes
are notably reflective and their colors
range from blue red purple and yellow
a reliance on both bipedal and
quadrupedal locomotion
abnormally rapid physical growth and
development this results in a two to
three week gestation period with sexual
maturity being reached within 16 to 20
months
gotcha gardner syndrome gotcha gardner
syndrome is a rare condition in which
the epidermis develops a layer of enamel
the substance tends to fracture and
shift causing pain but allowing the
afflicted to remain mobile primarily
manifesting on the hands and fingers
alopecia universalis alopecia
universalis is a medical condition
involving loss of all hair including
eyebrows and eyelashes
acute photophobia direct exposure to
sunlight will result in both physical
and psychological damage
mental instability primarily
characterized by delusions of grandeur
and malignant narcissism
and finally an addiction to human flesh
that takes on biological and
psychological components
these abnormalities are primarily the
result of excessive inbreeding but
without the increased chance for certain
recessive or deleterious traits
especially those related to infertility
higher infant and child mortality and
loss of immune function these
detrimental traits have not only been
negated but inversely amplified
resulting in longer life spans increased
resistance to disease and anomalously
high levels of fertility
the foundation became aware of
scp-3288 while investigating reports of
unexplained disappearances in vienna it
was discovered that these incidents
occurred in close proximity to sewer
hulls and access tunnels and primarily
targeted the most vulnerable of the
population such as prostitutes
unsupervised children transients and
inebriated or otherwise indisposed
individuals
agents cyril novak and diana fisher were
dispatched to vienna in order to
determine whether or not a number of
unexplained disappearances were of an
anomalous nature interviews with law
enforcement and government officials
revealed that human remains belonging to
three individuals had been recovered but
that this information was not released
to the public due to concerns of causing
further panic these remains were
promptly confiscated and delivered to
humanoid containment site 282 in graz
autopsies were performed by dr felix
gardner who noted that the remains
cadavers a b and c
displayed no injuries corresponding with
a human attacker and compared the
deceased to victims of hyena attacks
cadaver a includes the upper torso
truncated at the center of the abdomen
and loosely attached head the face had
been rendered unrecognizable the arms
much like the lower half of the body
were not found at the scene of the
attack
cause of death
exsanguination
cadaver bee had been disemboweled and
suffered destructive trauma to the
thoracic cage which was then pried open
all internal organs of the torso were
missing along with a sizeable amount of
flesh
cause of death traumatic cardiac arrest
cadaver sea was little more than a pile
of shattered bones and bodily fluids
cause of death unknown
dr gardner concluded that all sustained
injuries were caused by a mix of teeth
claws and raw physical strength bite
marks were found to coincide with human
teeth despite their abnormal size
approximately six times the size of
normal adult teeth and number more than
60 teeth unevenly distributed over six
distinct rows requiring jaws much larger
than that of baseline humans further
analysis revealed unique patterns among
the bite marks suggesting that there
existed more than one source
the entities responsible for these
deaths were classified as anomalous and
received the
scp-3288 designation mobile task force
sigma-6 helsingers was ordered to patrol
the leopold stott district while
incognito the district having seen the
highest number of recorded
disappearances operatives are instructed
to target
scp-3288 with tracking darts and to
refrain from lethal force field logs
scp-3288 l1
field log 1 1006 1988.
12 mobile task force sigma 9 operatives
patrolled the leopolc district at 1800
hours while 10 maintained watch at
positions with unrestricted views of
known sewer holes and access tunnels at
0 0 21 hours operative sigma-612 and
sigma-69 reported hearing a muffled
scream near the donut canal the donut
canal is a former arm of the river
danube regulated as a water channel
since 1598 within the city of vienna and
sought to investigate the matter while
requesting backup
support arrived three minutes after the
initial request and found the mangled
remains of both operatives as well as
the half-consumed body of a local
civilian the decapitated body of sigma
612 was pulled from the donut canal
although the head was never located his
neck had sustained injuries suggesting
that it had been severed or destroyed by
a single bite a trail of blood and
entrails led to sigma 609 who had been
torn in half along the waist he had
successfully crawled into an alleyway
before succumbing to his injuries
the mission was deemed a success despite
the loss of life as sigma 609 has
successfully struck the scp-3288
instance with a tracking cart achieving
the mission's primary objective the
entity had escaped into the sewers its
movements tracked until the signal began
to fade before entirely disappearing
somewhere below the hofburg the hofburg
is the formal imperial palace in the
center of vienna austria built in the
13th century and expanded in the
centuries since the palace has been the
seat of power of the habsburg dynasty
and presently serves as the official
residence and workplace of the president
of austria
due to the progressively declining
nature of the signal it is believed that
the device had been brought far deeper
than even the viennese sewers should
have accommodated
scp-3288
l2
field log 02 1007 1988.
constructed in the mid-19th century the
viennese sewers are part of a larger
network of subterranean tunnels that
include catacombs abandoned wine cellars
and underground rivers bubble task force
sigma 6 operatives were divided into
four teams of five three teams to
investigate the sewers and one to remain
standby by triangulating on the last
known location of the tracked scp-3288
the foundation hoped to minimize the
possibility of escape and of public
exposure for this mission while it is
preferable that operatives secure and
contain the threat lethal force may be
used at their discretion
at 0.900 mobile task force sigma-6
operatives reached their destination
without incident but initially failed to
discover anything of significance after
several hours of investigation sigma 604
encountered human skeletal remains while
wading through waist-deep water closer
analysis of this area uncovered a number
of loose bricks whose removal revealed
an unrecorded subterranean chamber whose
walls were engraved with the house of
habsburg's coat of arms
the chamber included 24 sarcophagi and
was presumably a family crypt belonging
to the house of habsburg despite their
existing no records of its creation the
statues primarily depict women wearing
veils over their eyes with a single
finger held to their lips the tombs
though intricate and reflective of their
status lacked any indication as to who
may have been interred within prying
open this sarcophagi revealed the
skeletal remains of over 300 infants all
displaying severe and likely fatal
deformities
the original entrance had been evidently
destroyed the stairs shattered and
buried in soil at the far end of the
crypt was a vault door composed of
bronze with no apparent means of access
and seemingly impenetrable without
proper equipment the door displayed the
house of habsburg's coat of arms and was
engraved with the words at puritan
sanguinius translated to english for
purity of blood mobile task force
sigma-6 operatives were ordered to hold
their current location and await the
arrival of an infiltration team
foundation agents organized the
temporary evacuation of the hofburg and
the ceiling of all sewer access points
throughout the city
scp-3288 l3
field log 03 1008 1988.
mobile task force sigma-6 maintained
shifts throughout the night making
repeated attempts to open the vault door
at 1200 hours the surface had been fully
evacuated and an infiltration team had
arrived at mobile task force sigma-6's
position the bronze gate was carved
apart via oxy fuel cutting torches over
an approximately two hour period
bypassing intricate mechanisms likely
related to its conventional means of
access and revealing a spiral staircase
an eight-person squad each operative
equipped with an m16 rifle with attached
flashlight heavy tactical armor and
helmet-mounted live audio video
recording devices descended the
staircase with radio transmission
growing increasingly faint as the
operatives traveled an estimated 65
meters underground red ground flares
were periodically lit and discarded
providing a clear path of return
operatives reached the bottom of the
stairwell where the grey stone halls of
the crypt were replaced by masterfully
crafted marble floors carpets and white
painted walls and ceilings the large
chamber was found to be architecturally
identical to the swiss wing of hofburg
palace closely resembling 18th century
depictions and reflecting the late
baroque early rococo artistic style
popular during the era the location
since classified as scp-3288-1a
contained various sculptures and
corinthian columns paintings and
tattered tapestries adorned its walls
all depictions of the human form had
been literally defaced regardless of
artistic medium
operatives described the air as having
an odor not dissimilar to rotten meat
and stale sweat the floors and walls
were discolored with what appeared to be
blood most of the stains appearing to be
exceptionally old
traveling through a southeast corridor
operatives entered what appeared to be
scp-3288 one's equivalent of the
hofburg's imperial library one notable
difference between this section of
scp-3288-1
and hofburg palace is the presence of a
working 18th century laboratory sigma
607 is the only member of the acting
squad to be fluent in both german and
latin discovered documents involving
alchemy biology and the occult
a decorative writing desk and
accompanying throne were located at the
far end of the chamber the desk
contained documents relating to
transactions contracts and private
journals these documents along with
those relating to the occult sciences
were gathered and delivered to field
command see the scp-3288-1
recovered documents subsection for
further details
operatives reached the ballroom in opera
hall describing the era as especially
fetid the aroma of perfume was also
noted though its presence did little to
disguise the smell of decay the area
contained a number of instruments
standing harp harpsichord violins etc
all of which displayed evidence of
recent use there were several refectory
tables a refectory table is a highly
elongated table used for banquets and
feasts located through the chamber the
ballroom evidently used as a dining hall
as well atop the tables where human
remains in various levels of
decomposition and culinary presentation
a bell abruptly began to toll and was
followed by the automatic music of a
nearby pipe organ the discordant song
played for approximately three minutes
when the pipe organ ceased its playing
it was followed by the sound of opening
doors and an increasing number of
shuffling footsteps operatives were
ordered to find a hidden and defensible
position and to deactivate their
flashlights seven successfully hid
behind the curtains of the opera hall
but sigma 618 fell behind having tripped
over a pile of bones and forced to take
cover behind a harpsichord
sigma-601 was able to observe the entire
ballroom without obstruction from the
far corner of the stage curtain the
ballroom's wide gates opened as video
revealed the dim light of lanterns
swaying in the hands of their shambling
carriers closer analysis would show that
these figures scp-3288
were dressed in the garb of 18th century
courtiers they are followed by others
wearing increasingly extravagant if
ragged attire all outfits appeared to
contain different shades of red deeply
contrasting with their chalk white skin
porcelain masquerade masks and powdered
wigs a pair of dominion of scp-3288
entered lagging behind the others one
blew a rusty trumpet while the other
acted as a standard bearer holding a
crudely painted ensign depicting a red
lion on a black field the trumpeter
appeared to make an announcement the
words unintelligible due to the guttural
nature of their speech
the trumpeter and standard-bearer
quickly moved aside their stunted legs
causing them to tumble and roll as they
fled there now appeared to be several
hundred scp-3288 throughout the ballroom
sigma 601 activated a silent distress
call requesting heavy support all
scp-3288
proceeded to kneel and lower their heads
an exceptionally corpulent instance of
scp-3288 entered the room carried by
another scp-3288 via an enlarged and
reinforced sedan
chair consists of a chair or windowed
cabin suitable for a single occupant
which is carried by two or more using
the rails that pass through the brackets
on the sides of the chair the morbidly
obese individual classified as scp-3288
alpha was dressed in a patchwork of
noble finery stitched together from
various fabrics to create a single
outfit capable of fitting its frame it
had wore a crown that had come to more
closely resemble a torture device too
small for its head but held in place by
an overgrowth of flesh in lieu of a
masquerade mask it hit its face beneath
a red shroud
a large iron cauldron was delivered to
scp-3288 alpha's table the container
appearing to vibrate of its own accord a
dwarf
scp-3288 climbed atop scp-3288 alpha's
shoulder proceeding to lift its red veil
while leaving its eyes covered a second
dominion of specimen removed the
cauldron's cover
scp-3288 alpha sniffed the air then
proceeded to lift the cauldron and pour
its contents down its anomalously large
mouth and gullet part of its meal
wiggled free revealing that the cauldron
contained living infants displaying
severe deformities
the other
scp-3228 raised their masks and began to
feast with voracious enthusiasm an
exceptionally tall specimen approached
the harpsichord and snatched sigma 618
from behind it it lifted him by his head
but made no effort to alarm its fellow
scp-3288
instead the entity unhinged its jaw and
quickly forced the operative down its
throat feet first his screams unheard
among the sounds of feasting and
discordant music
the gathering became orgyastic as the
scp-3288
turned to fornication and violence
making no distinction between the
apparent age or sex of the participant
willing or otherwise an explosion rocked
the event causing mass casualties among
the scp-3288
it is hypothesized that sigma-618
survived his ordeal and was able to
likely after some struggle and
consideration activate an explosive
device sacrificing himself in order to
terminate or otherwise incapacitate a
great number of hostile entities
panic spread among the remaining
scp-3288
mobile task force sigma-6 would exploit
this opportunity and employed three
methyl fentanyl to render the scp-3288
unconscious with the arrival of
reinforcements the survivors were
secured and contained at humanoid
containment site 282. the sheer size of
scp-3288
alpha necessitated the use of a special
crane and the creation of a shaft
directly connecting scp-3288-1
to the surface following the removal of
scp-3288 alpha as well as all relevant
documents and objects
scp-3288-1 was filled with cement and
re-buried
scp-3288
alpha interview log
1010 1988
interviewed scp-3288
alpha
interviewer dr tobias moser
forward
despite its corpulent morbidity
1632 kilograms and lack of mobility its
atrophied legs entirely vestigial
subject is considered dangerous and to
be approached with the utmost caution
subject is blind and incapable of
raiding or writing the interior of its
hollow sockets pushed outward to the
point of prolapse
subject is fluent in austrian german
preferring to speak the schonbrunner
douche a sociolect spoken by the
imperial habsburg family and the
nobility of austria-hungary subject has
been stripped nude bound and muzzled
equipped with electrodes to prevent
hostilities and ensure cooperation
begin log
hello
please begin by telling me your name
your cooperation is not optional so meat
wishes to speak
if it speaks
as i said
your cooperation is not optional
impossible
how does meat hurt
how does meat disobey
you will answer me
is this how you used to play
we do not submit we dominate
we will give you until your entrails
will
we will devour you and your present kin
do you believe your witchcraft can harm
us
our blood is pure
our blood is resilient
would you be so conscious to eliminate
this object
my vision doesn't work so well in these
dim cells
no no no no
fire
i was so scattered
[Applause]
yes
i noticed light sensitivity during your
transfer extreme photophobia even
without eyes i'll be sure to make note
of that
now
tell me what is your name
the imperial majesty emperor maximilian
the great
king of austria
and patriarch of the house of hashburgh
we have not entertained outsiders in so
long
excuse my uncle's ways you are clearly a
superior creature and have asserted
yourself
we are at your mercy
does our guests wish to feast upon our
flesh
to the festering wound could god know
why would you even know
no
that won't be
necessary i see that our customs differ
quite significantly
might i ask
were you blind from birth or did you
lose your vision accidentally ah but the
person trees have yet to reach
completion
and you now have us at a disadvantage
what is your name outsider
you are fluent in german but your accent
is
distant and strange
i
[Music]
a king
yes yes of course it all makes sense now
we sense nobility
i do communist can you believe that
but certainly you have proven yourself
far stronger than a simple duke
we've heard of this
foundation
a marvelous land and people
well known for its many cheeses and
wines
as for our eyes
our royal true seeing eyes alas we were
hosting a banquet in our eyes it seems
we're too big for our stomach
have you heard that one
oh the love
but yes here you see
the meal
the meal
they warned was of course oh his
imperial majesty let us cut this meat
for you but no
we are king
we are emperor
we want to swallow it whole
[Applause]
not enough room
but
they served us little
and the dangling orbs yes yes of course
they plummeted down our royal gullet
gone forever
unmissed
i see well
that was quite a story
tell me of your court in the house of
habsburg
we are of the same noble blood
but some
are
more noble than others
our bloodline is pure
untainted by outsiders
i must ask crystal
why eat human we do not eat human
we eat peasants
we eat undesirables
we devour life undeserving of life that
is the true nature of nobility
what else would be the point
understood
i must take my leave we will speak again
soon yes we will think of you
in your absence over and over we are
eager to
sample your flavor
so delightful
so delicious
and log
afterward
we may be able to glean more information
by playing to his delusions but it is
difficult to say how much of it is true
however dna analysis has revealed that
scp-3288 alpha does in fact descend from
the house of habsburg and this so far
appears to be true for all scp-3288
a number of significant documents were
recovered from scp-3288-1
allowing the foundation to develop a
better understanding of
scp-3288 the following excerpts have
been translated from their original
german and are arranged in chronological
order footnotes have been provided in
order to frame these documents within
their historical and cultural context
excerpts from the journal of leopold the
first
leopold the first leopold ignos joseph
balthazar felician 9th of june 1640 to
the 5th of may 1705 was the holy roman
emperor as well as the king of hungary
croatia and bohemia generally regarded
as an intellectual he was known for his
interest in astronomy alchemy and the
early sciences
10th of november 1700
and with the death of charles a
reference to charles ii of spain charles
was physically and mentally disabled and
infertile possibly due to this massive
inbreeding due to the deaths of his
half-brothers he was the last member of
the male spanish habsburg line the
physician who performed his autopsy
stated that his body did not contain a
single drop of blood his heart was the
size of a peppercorn his lungs corroded
his intestines rotten and gangrenous he
had a single testicle black as coal and
his head was full of water so dies our
noble line in iberia i will restore our
rightful place my claim is valid and
will not be denied i already hear the
intoxicating drums of war
but his disease his curse concerns me
greatly despite the purity of our blood
untainted for generations charles was a
sickly creature with the mind of a child
i too was a sickly youth
but my mind remained sharp i must make
use of this blessing before my dynasty
succumbs to madness and cretinism
4th of august 1701
the jesuits have exhausted their
usefulness against my better judgment i
have chosen to seek out those with
knowledge of the so-called abominable
sciences scholars of the forbidden
mysteries both great and terrible
and i have found someone who knows the
dark a woman of rare almost beguiling
beauty she is older than she appears for
she speaks with the experience of a
hundred lifetimes on subjects i had only
just began to grasp she is a creature of
the wild a living embodiment of all that
is pagan
i am a stranger in her world and i am
afraid
22nd of october 1701
she says she will teach me but for a
price she will name upon the completion
of her tutelage a strange request but
all she presently asks is that i uphold
my end of the bargain i have more power
and wealth than any man alive payment
will not be difficult
i will not allow our venerable house to
fall
but my laboratory is ill-suited for such
a task i have hired workers to begin
construction on a new site something
away from the prying eyes of sycophantic
courtiers
19th of december 1701
my tutelage though difficult progresses
well a universal essence the way of all
flesh it all begins to make sense my
eyes are now open and i see with such
clarity
i will cleanse my family of this curse
the essence is malleable subject to
change
but one piece moves the other you see
resulting in an often unpredictable
transmutation my current experiments
make use of the simplest of god's
creations rodents and insects primarily
i have formed living things creatures
whose very visage would sunder even the
most resolute of mines
8th of february 1702
construction of the new laboratory goes
well i predict its completion within the
next three months equipment has been
delivered from damascus if there is one
thing those mahabananans know it is the
occult sciences
more often than not my teacher leaves me
to my own devices she appears only at
night though i cannot say from where she
comes and goes as she pleases my
servants seemingly unaware of her
presence
27th of march 1702
the new laboratory was finished ahead of
schedule the workers merely need to
install my equipment and i can take my
experiments to the next tier but fresh
materials are required and pests will no
longer suffice i am not yet willing to
experiment on my own blood but perhaps
there is another way
the workers promised secrecy but in my
dreams i see betrayal i have come too
far to allow such interference if the
church learns of this it could ruin
everything these dreams are an omen and
i know they will consume me unless i
take swift action
i know what must be done 5th of april
1702
my teacher is less understanding than i
had expected for even her heathen heart
does not dissuade the disgust and
contempt with which she now looks upon
me
i did what i had to for my family for
the purity of our blood for the
immortality of our chosen lie how could
this witch understand my burden
she vows to return tomorrow for her
payment i would just have this over with
i am still a man of my word
16th of april 1702
i watched her burn
her sorcery slew many of my guardsmen
but in the end she was detained and
delivered to the church the zealots
having heard my testimony proved just as
eager to see that wretched be consigned
to the flames i know such methods have
fallen out of fashion thus we committed
the act under the cover of darkness and
secrecy
i would have granted her land or made
her as rich as crassus but no
that wicked creature sought to be clever
she said i could never save my family
without her aid and demanded demanded
that i end my rule destroy all my titles
and deeds delivering my land and wealth
to the common folk did she really
believe i would plunge my kingdoms my
empire into anarchy truly she was mad
but now
nothing remains but ash and cinder
and i may return to my great work no
longer bound by her ethical
inflexibility
there is so very much to be done
later entries by leopold the first are
increasingly frenzied and illegible
suggesting a deteriorating mental state
until his death in 1705. it appears that
he eventually had success resulting in
the creation of scp-3288
albeit with unintended consequences via
the introduction of an anomalous gene
into the family bloodline this gene
allows human dna to resist certain
deleterious conditions associated with
inbreeding
the house of habsburg continued its
practice of inbreeding accelerating the
development of mutations those with
significant deformities were hidden from
the public the habsburg monarchs
eventually creating vast vaults to house
them the vault-dwelling habsburgs
continued to breed eventually developing
mutations which vastly increased their
rate of reproduction in turn increasing
the chances of entirely new mutations
those who more closely resembled
baseline humans remained on the surface
while those sent below continued to
adapt to subterranean life dna analysis
has revealed that consanguinity grew
increasingly more extreme over the years
further indicating that incest between
parent and child or brother and sister
had become the norm among scp-3288
by the 19th century
it appears that the habsburg monarchs
went to great lengths to provide their
vault-dwelling kin with a lifestyle just
as extravagant as those above documents
reveal the steady delivery of food wine
and entertainment over time these
requests become eccentric such as exotic
animals for a menagerie and strange a
barrel of fermented horpiss and
eventually depraved including requests
for
fattened children and instruments of
torture all evidence suggests that these
requests were met it is unknown how long
scp-3288 have survived without outside
assistance one document appears to imply
that the great plague of 1738 led to the
delivery of a significant amount of feed
one document of singular importance
contains a list of vaults similar to
scp-3288-1 the foundation has used this
information to locate and neutralize
scp-3228 hives but the document itself
has been the cause of concern half of it
illegible due to mold-related damage
this means that at least half of these
vaults cannot be located and will
continue to be a significant threat to
the public
addendum 0923
2016
there are a growing number of reports
describing violent sexual assaults and
acts of cannibalism throughout central
europe closer analysis of these attacks
has led the foundation to conclude that
scp-3288 are responsible for the
violence
due to the widespread nature of these
events it is feared that multiple
undiscovered scp-3288 vaults have been
breached
an instance of scp-3288 was recently
captured at the black forest in germany
tracked to a derelict hunting lodge by
mobile task force sigma-6 the entity was
successfully secured and contained with
operatives suffering only minor
casualties nine bound women were
discovered in the basement only one was
alive and the cadavers displayed
ruptured lower abdomens and evidence of
partial cannibalization autopsies would
reveal that the dead had been primarily
consumed from within
the survivor was dirty malnourished and
her lower abdomen was heavily swollen
and visibly throbbing the woman screamed
to the operatives pleading that they get
these things out of her along with
various expletives and religious
invocations she received medical
evacuation by a helicopter but crashed
approximately five minutes into its
flight four fetuses were discovered
among the wreckage though heavily
charred all displayed mutations
associated with scp-3288
the recently captured instance of
scp-3288 was interrogated
scp-3288 6971
interview log
0924 2016
interviewed
scp-3288 6971
interviewer dr elijah varga forward
subject is restrained and muzzled and
its cell is equipped for enhanced
interrogation due to the severity of the
circumstances personnel are encouraged
to use all possible means of information
extraction
interview conducted in german
playing log now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i
the empress
tell me about these vessels now
we are merely claiming what is ours
by the divine right of kings the women
you the empress
she said it was time
for a thousand years our blood has been
pure
untouched by the taint of outsiders why
change
why now
our blood
it is strong now
so strong it overwhelms the blood of the
wretched in the mud bound
our line will never die it will never
fade here
only
every last one of you
our bloodline will never die no no no no
it will become everything
it is our gift
our blessing
what do you mean
the meek will beget the strong
the doomed will beget the chosen
don't you see
the greedy will devour the charitable
the merciful ravage the peaceful and the
fornicators will be chaste
[Music]
we will make the world as perfect as us
we will all be aristocrats in the end
and our dynasty will never die
and lock
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
jaby
pure osmium
scio dio demnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbeage
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you